in 1984 orgreave in south yorkshire was
the scene of some of the bitterest
clashes during the year-long minor
strike
when the pits closed communities
suffered and many feared for the future
of the entire region
but 35 years on this area has undergone
a remarkable transformation
the first thing we've done here is we've
converted this vehicle into
an electric vehicle today orgreave is
the home of sheffield university's
advanced manufacturing research centre
and it's helping put britain out front
in the competitive market of precision
engineering this site has been a hotbed
really for
industry research and translational
skills to come together
the boss here insists that with proper
funding it is possible to repeat the
success
across the entire north of england
and proof that early investment in
innovation pays dividends
can be found just down the road this
high-tech tool company was founded by a
former member of the advanced
manufacturing research centre
it uses their know-how to win huge
contracts against multinational
competitors
we're doing fantastically well we
offer a wide variety of service to our
customers we export globally
we've actually recruited six since the
initial lockdown began in march
it's the success of northern companies
like this that the government is now
trying to build on
the conservatives won the last election
thanks to dozens of traditional labour
seats in the industrial heartland of the
north turning blue
many for the first time since then
they've repeatedly insisted they would
repay that newfound loyalty
with more investment nick fletcher is
one of the new intake of tory mps
he's the first ever conservative to win
the labour stronghold of don valley in
south yorkshire
what does levelling up mean to you it
can take many forms people desperately
need to feel as though the government
cares about the people
in the north i think they feel as though
they've been left behind
for such a long time and
everything happens in the south or
that's at least how they feel
and there's definitely a certain amount
of truth in that but for many people
here
it's not just about the money if you
still have power centralized in
whitehall
if your leveling up fund is a beauty
pageant
for projects and for parts of the north
the midlands to kind of
parade in front of officials that's not
really trusting people
and it's not really giving power back to
people if you don't trust people if you
don't give them real power
then i don't think that really does
start to close the divide between north
and south
there's clearly a huge amount of
economic potential in the north of
england
and this government has repeated its
commitment to level up
but serious questions remain about the
level of investment
and also the amount of control that
westminster will continue
to exert and the stakes are really high
if boris johnson gets it wrong
then the people who lent him their votes
last time could disappear
safely for ridge sky news